make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so professor Hulk you know this is
interesting
that we're getting professor Hulk in the
movies cuz I mean for the most part
we're just kind of like yep we're
getting professor Hulk that's really
just what it is and they're not wrong I
mean it's essentially professor hawk
right he looks the part
uh but what does this mean okay so
people are kind of looking at this and
they're like oh do we get professor Hoff
like professor Hawk is gonna decimate
all no it's not either because professor
Hulk's like the weakest Verte like
normally the weakest like one of the
weakest versions of the Incredible Hulk
a huge reason why okay so in Marvel
Comics
you've got like two significant runs of
the Incredible Hulk three if you count
Greg pack but Greg Pak was more of like
let's just show a story for The
Incredible Hulk just like smashes things
and it's like it's angry as he's never
been right so like Planet Hulk one where
Hulk heart of the monster you know what
we're hoping after smash all that kind
of stuff just like this insane level of
power with the Incredible Hulk is really
all it is but in terms of my character
development that all belongs to bill
Mantlo and Peter David
so between 1980 and 1985 with the
Incredible Hulk to forty five to three
thirteen which is which was Bill Matt
Lowe's when I'm pretty sure I think
there were some annuals like ten to
thirteen or something like that in there
and then you look at Peter David and it
was like it was insane it was like 1989
and 1998 which was the incredible I want
to say it was 328 running up to 467 but
I also want to say there's like a like a
smattering of issues that he didn't
write um between those two guys they
totally reworked the incredible book
right because before that like when it
was Stan Lee and Jack Kirby The
Incredible Hulk was just kind of like um
a mindless beast more or less right like
mindless Hulk Savage Hawk it wasn't
until they came along that like they
started focusing more on like Bruce
Banner and like the abusive nature of
his dad right so like when you read this
what do you hear about the stories about
how like Brian Banner the father of
Bruce was really abusive and like
children's mom and all that kind of
stuff that that was all bill Mantlo and
Peter David but the bigger thing about
that is that they took the incredible
whole concept and instead of doing what
but Stan Lee and Jack Kirby did and say
well the Incredible Hulk is just this
like dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde asked persona
right like Bruce banners dr. Jekyll The
Incredible Hulk mr. Hyde instead of just
like sticking with that what they did is
they started creating like all these
other versions of being kind
Hauk so you have like devil Hulk things
like that joke fix it was actually a
build on what already existed right
because like the original Incredible
Hulk run issues one through six The
Incredible Hulk was great but because of
the various issues with inks and so on
and so forth they had to make him green
they brought him back and they said well
the great Hulk was like sure the first
iteration of the Incredible Hulk
but that's Joe fix it via the the green
version is like the second version to
manifest right so looks like multiple
personalities right like Joe fix it was
the first personality savage Hulk the
the green Hulk was the second
personality and then there were like all
these things that kind of came out along
the way but what it did is a coalescing
the story that they came out with a
credible hope number 377 and what he did
is it basically said okay like Bruce
Banner is constantly tormented by like
the memories of his father so on and so
forth and and because of that like dodge
Sampson he basically realized that like
the the various Incredible Hulk personas
that were popping up great Hulk and and
like like Joe fix-it gray Hawks savage
hope things like that we're just like
alternate personalities of Bruce Banner
that what he was suffering from was
multiple personality disorder
and it just happened to be that the
gamma bomb allowed those personalities
to manifest in the form of like
incredible hulks instead of just
different versions of Bruce Banner right
so instead of Bruce Banner walking
around you know in the Bruce Banner form
but with a mind of someone named like
like Samantha instead it was the
Incredible Hulk and the result was that
that Samson said okay we have to we have
to try to find a way to like use thira p
to fix this and so kind of going into
the mind of Bruce at the same time Bruce
Banner was actually also dealing with
like the memory of his mother something
along those lines anyway the decision
was made to basically merge savage Paul
Gray Joe fix-it Hulk and Bruce Banner
into a singular entity and the
perception or the belief was that Bruce
Banner was fixed because what you got
was this fourth persona that was called
a professor though the reason why
professor is like the weakest version of
all the Incredible Hulk is because all
the Incredible Hulk old versions of them
have essentially unlimited strength the
only real exception to that I would say
is joke fiction but it's more because
he's like a mobster and he kind of
operates as a mobster as opposed to like
savage Hulk with unrivaled strength and
things like that but with with with
professor Hulk the way this works is
essentially the mind of Bruce Banner
with all the strengths of the savage
Hulk but the angry
he gets it basically caps instead of it
just having like unlimited anger and and
then with it unlimited strength what
would happen is that the that Bruce
Banner gets really like professor would
reach a point where he would become so
angry he would revert back into Bruce
Banner and so it was kind of weird
because there was no unlimited strength
there right so it's unlike professor can
reach like maestro hawk levels or like
rogue record Hulk levels that would
never happen like that it's just not
it's not the way his character is design
but what it does is it throws the
element into the MCU where you've
basically got like all the power the
credible Hulk as we've seen him with the
mind of Bruce and this is important
because when it comes to the Incredible
Hulk you know in terms of how we see him
he is in the MCU not really a mindless
beast but it's certainly not really like
that scalpel right like he's not a
precision instrument you don't send him
in and say hey we need you to like take
out everybody in this room except for
like these two guys right let the
Incredible Hulk just like everyone's
gonna die it just starts like tearing
everything apart like just smashing
things is what he does but when you've
got Bruce Banner the mind of Bruce
Banner and possession of the incredible
Hawks power now it suddenly becomes a
lot more nuanced right like he can fight
Thanos with a cunning mind now it's not
like a warrior's mind but it's not like
we're talking about taskmaster twenty
masters with like the power of the
Incredible Hulk in which case that would
just be decimated like that like it
would be it would be it wouldn't be fair
taskmaster with the Incredible Hulk
powers fighting nanos would be would be
insane because taskmaster like though
because of the formula he tooks the
formula that he consumed he basically
like mimics people's fighting styles
right I mean I'm a little famous really
has a fighting style but nonetheless you
know we digress here professor Hulk is
going to be an answer to the question
what would happen if the Incredible Hulk
were smart as Bruce Banner well that's
basically what it is now there is an
actual version like that right I mean
professor is basically just like Bruce
banners mind and the incredible hulks
body there is a version that actually
came out much later that was written who
wants that that wrote that I want I
think with the Mark Waid run but it was
basically like merciful or something
Allah Muslim sorry it was a doc green
Hulk and doc green hope was basically
The Incredible Hulk who was smarter than
Bruce Banner Ashton and the comic like
oh I'm sorry in in an interview Mark
Waid was like yeah man like like like
Doc Green Hulk is smarter than Banner
was so basically it's like a super
genius version of the
I dabble Hulk himself as opposed to like
professor which is the Bruce Banner mind
in the body of the Incredible Hulk but
still it'll be interesting I mean it's
not gonna be a game-changer right I mean
unless they decide to change it because
they could they could basically say this
is like a world breaker Hulk s character
it's like World War Hulk with the mind
of your spanner I don't think they'll do
that I think they're going with the
actual professor which means it like
like he's not you're not gonna see
anything different right I mean you may
see him do better in a fight with a nose
but you're not gonna see him like
crushed a nose in one pot right like
it's like he's gonna be that level of
power he's not gonna be Wahlburgers Hulk
or even like part of the monster right
because part of the monster was like a
whole different like it was a whole
different level like you had work
breaker home during like the World War
Hulk event and then you have part of the
monster when Bruce Banner discovered
like a wishing well you know it was like
I wish I could fight forever you know
and like ended up being transformed to
the realm of Dormammu and like like your
mom or sister like gumar whatever went
to dr. strange it was like you have to
get in out of my realm because they're
destroying entire world like they're
they're going to destroy it like they're
literally gonna fracture my dimension
and shatter into a million pieces
because they're just so strong but but
like it's crazy because during that
story it went part of the monster either
it's I think it's when Doctor Strange is
in the realm of Dormammu when he's
watching everything unfold and like he
makes his offhand remark where he's like
deep red of Hulk is way beyond world
breaker at this point it's kind of nuts
for some reason people seem to believe
that like part of like the heart of
monsters story is actually real breaker
halt you could be further from the truth
but the fact remains that that that
it'll be interesting this is not like
from what I can tell if it's anything
like they come in with version it's not
gonna be a game-changer it's not gonna
like totally throw everything off it's
why do you kind of all it's gonna win it
these like professor is gonna show up
and like all the Avengers have been
defeated he's like you know what the
heck with it I'll defeat Thanos by
myself that's not gonna happen because
he's just not that strong he's not he's
not really that capable it'll be the
Incredible Hulk with the mind of Bruce
Banner and that'll really be it but
again like it does kind of leave the
door open for future versions of The
Incredible Hulk people you could see
because we might see maestro right I
mean like if the whole idea of the
quantum realm rings true and we're
seeing time travel they'd be kind of
crazy we probably won't but it'd be kind
of crazy if we saw them like go into the
future and like the world's been
decimated by nuclear war and like
dystopias they're basically like this
giant city the
hope rules as maestro ver he's like old
with this beard and it's just like twice
as strong as he normally is I mean like
if it's we saw that that'd be cool but
it opens the door for those cousins for
like other versions of the Incredible
Hulk
for like devil hole and all that kind of
cool stuff you'd be it'd be awesome to
see those things on pole but in terms of
what you guys are going to see now um
you're gonna see a pretty
straightforward version of what you've
seen so far is it's not gonna be
anything out of the ordinary anything
beyond what you've seen it's like um you
need like a whole new level of power or
anything like that it's not like what's
going super saiyan or anything along
those lines it's just you know hook with
the mind of roost and that's that's
really about it but again you know
professor hope explained it's pretty
straightforward I mean it's it's
basically just a merging of incredible
whole characters now following that it's
kind of a cool thing following that doc
Samson realized that Bruce wasn't
actually fixed so he was only designed
to be a temporary thing like I mean we
saw that run on for a little while and
if that didn't like professor Hulk had
his own superhero team
I came over the name of it but it
started with an A but he had his own
superhero team for a little while um but
eventually it all just kind of reverted
back to normal and and really had
happened by the mid nineties for the
most part like it was one of the things
that came out of onslaught saga I'm
pretty sure when like Bruce Banner was
separated from the Hulk and the Hulk
wait to be run back to Dean like
mindless and savage again and then that
led into like the whole thing of you
know the incredible hawk becoming the
horseman war for like apocalypse and
like fighting the juggernaut like
stopping him in his tracks and all that
kind of crazy stuff but still you know
it's if it'll be a cool thing you know
for us to see it'll be a cool little set
of events but uh yeah we that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop all white
then I will catch you all later
[Music]